[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء نبدا بالعناوين
خطه من ثلاث مراحل تنتهي بلقائه مع الاسد
في عمل
انهيار
اقتصادي
افضل من الاوروبيين
مصدر لبناني يؤكد جندي اليونيفيل قتل
برصاصه في الراس وحزب الله يضع سكان
العاقبيه في الوجهه
لتفضيله تويتر المستثمرون في تسلاي
يتذمرون من ايرون ماسك وسعر سهم الشركه
ينخفض للنصف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ما كان عدوا لدودا يوم امس
لمانعا ان يكون صديقا اليوم فالخصام في
السياسه لا يدوم هذا هو لسان حال الرئيس
التركي الذي يجدد مره اخرى رغبته الشديده
بلقاء بشار الاسد لا بل يسر على ان يتم
الامر في اقرب وقت ممكن ولان النظام الاسد
رفض التقارب في وقت سابق لجا اردوغان الى
من قد يغير راي الاسد الرئيس الروسي هو
المفتاح لذلك اردوغان اقترح على بوتن خطه
من ثلاث مراحل لاعاده تطبيع مجددا لقاءات
بين انقره ودمشق تبدا من مسؤولي
الاستخبارات تتصاعد تدريجيا لتصل لمستوى
وزراء الخارجيه والدفاع ومن ثم ما يريدها
اردوغان لقاء الاسد وجهه لكن بشرط بسيط
وهو حضور فوتان على ذات الطاوله
خصم الامس حليف اليوم عباره قد تختصر
المشهد السياسي وربما الجغرافي المقبل على
الشمال السوري بعد ان كان الاسد صوره
الديكتاتور الاكبر في نظر الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان بات مشروع تجاوز الخلافات
مطروحا اليوم على طاوله الحوار بواسطه
روسيه
[تصفيق]
اردوغان الذي ذهب الى حد اقتراح قمه
ثلاثيه لتسريع المسار الدبلوماسي مع دمشق
اثناء زياره الرئيس التركي لتركمانستان
ولقائه مع بوتين بدر الاول باقتراح سلسله
اجتماعات لحل عقده الخلافات بين انقره
ودمشق والتي تجاوز عمرها العقد من الزمن
اقترحت في اتصال
على مستوى اجهزه الاستخبارات اولا ثم على
مستوى وزراء الدفاع ثم وزراء الخارجيه ثم
القاده
مبادره اردوغان ترافقت بشروط اولها
الوساطه الروسيه مصرحا ان هناك
30 كم على طول الحدود المشتركه
لكن وفق تجارب المنطقه تاتي التسويات بثمن
وباهظ احيانا مشروع التسويه الثلاثيه الذي
اقترحه الرئيس التركي قد يمر على جسرين
اساسيين القوات الكرديه شماليه سوريا التي
ترى ان من حقها حصد اثمان قتال داعش مع
القوات الامريكيه باداره ذاتيه تقيها ليس
فقط من الطموحات التركيه العابره للحدود
بل من عوده المحتمله لدمشق الى الحسكه
والتي قد تكون مكلفه عليها
جسرون ثاني او ضحيه ثانيه الا وهي
المعارضه السوريه المقيمه في تركيا او ما
تبقى منها اذا عمر العربيه
من الحسكه ينضم الينا صالح مسلم رئيس
المشترك لحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطيس الصالح
اهلا بك معنا في ايطار يمكن وضع هذا
المقترح قمه ثلاثيه بين اردوغان الاسد
وبوتن وفي هذا التوقيت بالذات
تحياتي لكم ولجميع مشاهديكم
لا اعلم يعني بالنسبه للسياسه التركيه
هي معدات الكردي يعني معادلات الشعب
الكردي سلام في الداخل وفي الخارج ومنذ
سبع سنوات هي تشن حرب على الكرد في الداخل
وفي الخارج وفي مناطقنا في شمال سوريا وفي
جنوب العراق هذه الحرب المستمر
من جديد ماذا استطيع ان افعل لاجلب
الاخرين الى جانبي
هل التطبيع مع نظام الاسد هو الحل برايك
بنسبه لتركيا
[موسيقى]
نحن قلنا روسيا عندما تحدثت اول مره عن
لقاء بشار
نحن قلنا انه الزواج قسري يعني لا لا يمكن
الجمع بين امور متناقضه كثيره اهداءات
كثيره تاريخيه وراه هنا ولكن روسيا يبدو
انها تحاول الجمع بين الاثنين مثل ما تفعل
باي زواج قصري ولهذا اعتقد انه من الصعب
همم القيام بكل شيء ولكن
اردوغان يحاول يعني يحاول الشده الاخرين
لمحاربه الشعب الكردي سواء في الداخل في
الخارج
هل له علاقه بالانتخابات في تركيا
نعم نعم هناك جانب بالانتخابات
منذ سبع سنوات في كل شيء في الداخل
والخارج الاقتصاد متداول العلاقه
الدبلوماسيه لم يبقى بيده سوى الروس
والامريكان حلف الناتو اللي يلعب عليهما
بالابتزاز
بامتزاز الطرفين والاتحاد الاوروبي يوميا
هو يبتعد عنهم لذلك على الصعيد الدبلوماسي
ايضا في الداخل السياسيه
[موسيقى]
يعني البارحه وهو اول امس وكذا ولهذا لا
يبقى ايضا
في المحيط مبنى البلديه على كل حال الصالح
ارجو منك ان تبقى معي نتذكر سويا مع
المشاهدين بعض تصريحات الرئيس التركي التي
هاجم فيها بشار الاسد في الاعوام الماضيه
رافضا الحوار مهما كان الثمن قبل طبعا ان
تتغير الامور الان ثم نعود اليك
غير مشروع
يلصون
هكذا انانيور هنا ركز يونيون سوريا سوريا
[موسيقى]
لازمته
خالص
[موسيقى]
يدفع ثمن هذا التقارب ان حصل
اكراد سوريا واكراد في شمال سوريا
المعارضه ايضا داخل تركيا وكيف برايك
سيتعاملون مع هذا التقارب اذا حصل
يخسر طرفان اعتقد الطرف الذي راعي على
تركيا التي تم تمنع الحمل السوري منذ سبع
سنوات منذ 2014 عندما اعترضت على القرار
2254 الى اليوم
معارضه التي كانت في حضن الاسد
ايضا اما نحن بالنسبه للاداره ذاتيه
الديمقراطيه
نورهان لا على تركيا ولا على الاسف نحن
كان لدينا خطنا ثالث تمسكنا به ولا زالنا
على الولايات المتحده هل انتم مراضون على
همم ردود الفعل الامريكي يعني في اطار
التهدئه وفي اطار دعمكم معنويا الولايات
المتحده همم هي واضحه ولكن البعض ينتقد
بانه الولايات المتحده لا تقدم دعاما اا
جديا لحل هذه الازمه ولا لحمايتكم
الولايات المتحده تلتزم بما اتفقنا عليه
سوى ما قال ما يعني العمل الذي قام به
الرئيس ترامب اما الاخرون فهم اهتمونا بما
تم الاتفاق عليه وهو محاربه داعش داعش
طبعا اراهانت عليه تركيا على اساس ان داعش
يمكن ان تقضي على القرد ولكن فشلت عندما
انكسر داعش
تبادلت السياسات التركيه ايضا نحن لازلنا
ملتزمون مع الولايات المتحده بمحاربه داعش
وهي صادقه في تعاملها معنى الى الان
والاعتداءات الاخيره التي حدثت فعلا اثرت
على همم محاربه داعش اثرت على كثير من
العمليات التي كانت تجري بالتنسيق مع
التحالف الدولي في مواجهه داعش ولهذا
امريكا اعترض على هذه العمليه العمليه
البريه وحتى هذا القصف الذي حدث حدث على
بعض قواعد الامريكيه التي تجمع وحدات
محاربه داعش الارهاب مع الامريكيين ولهذا
امريكا
لم تعدنا بانها ستتحنين او تحافظ علينا لم
تذهب اكثر من التعاون في مجال داعش وهذا
ما زالت تلتزم به
القضاء علينا
القضاء على الشعب الكردي ولهذا نحن طبعا
على الاقل نستطيع في مصالحنا مع التحالف
الدولي لمحاربه داعش وهذا ما نقوم به ان
يخفف ان العبد قليله شكرا
لحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطيسي
[موسيقى]
في تركيا ايضا شهدت مدينه اسطنبول تظاهرات
دعت اليها المعارضه رفضا لقرار سجن رئيس
بلديه المدينه المعارض اكرم امام اوغلو
ومنعه من العمل السياسي يقود هذا التجمع
رؤساء سته احزاب معارضه كبيره في تركيا من
ابرزهم رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري ورئيسه
حزب الخير القومي ورئيس حزب الديمقراطيه
والتقدم بالاضافه الى عشره رؤساء بلديات
ولايات كبرى في تركيا
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو في
كلمه له امام التجمع الاحتجاجي لانصار
المعارضه قال ان السلطه الحاكمه في تركيا
لا تحترم القانون ولا الاخلاق وتسعى لخنق
اصوات الناخبين
وهي لا تحترم القانون ولا الاخلاق كما
حاولت السلطه في تركيا تعطيل عمل بلديه
اسطنبول بعد خساره الانتخابات واريد ان
اشير الى انه تم تغيير القاضي الذي كان
موكلا بقضيته لانهم حسوا بانه لن يصدر
حكما كما يرغبون تركيا تقف على مفترق طرق
بين من يقبل بالسياده الوطنيه دون قيد او
شرط وبين من لديهم حساسيه من السياده
الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول ينضم الى مراسل العربيه زيدان
اهلا بك معنا بالنسبه لهذه التظاهرات التي
حصلت اليوم والكلمات التي القيت ابرز
المواقف
ما يراه كثيرون تاتي في نطاق استعراض
القوه من قبل المعارضه في قدره احزاب
المعارضه وتحديدا الطاوله السداسيه على
حشد الشارع همم لجهه حزب الشارع طبعا
المناوي لحزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس
اردوغان طبعا هذا القرار شجع المعارضه على
هذه التظاهره وكانت هناك انتقادات حاده
للقضاء بدايه من اكرم امام اوغلو الذي
انتقد القرار واليه عمل القضاء وايضا كان
هناك انتقادات من بقيه قاده الاحزاب الذين
شاركوا في هذه التظاهره لسيطره ما وصفوا
الحكومه على مؤسسات الدوله واا ذهب البعض
للحديث عن ان الدوله اليوم باتت الى
السياده وان تركيا على مفترق ما بين
السياده الوطنيه والتزام همم
وحريه المؤسسات وسياده القضاء وما بين ما
وصفه بعض بالفوضى لذلك التظاهر اليوم كانت
ربما هي الاولى بحسب ما اذكر هي الاولى
همم الطاوله السداسيه لسته احزام معارضه
هنا في اسطنبول همم طبعا كما ذكرت كانت
الاجواء في الشارع همم مشحونه رافضه
للقرار من قبل الانصار اكرم امام اوبلو
التقينا كثيرا منهم همم في همم اثناء
التظاهره الجميع عبر عن رفضه لهذه لهذا
القرار قرار المحكمه بالعموم همم اليوم
نشهد بدايه جديده للمعارضه في حشد الشارع
التركي يعني هذه التظاهره رغم ان همم
اعداد المتظاهرين او الذين شاركوا لم تكون
كبيره جدا لكن هي الرساله تحمل همم بعد
سياسي ان المعارضه قادره على حشد الشارع
في اكبر مدن تركيا همم وايضا همم ربما
نشهد مثل هذه التظاهرات في عديدنا المدن
التركيه لكن بالعموم الحمامات الانتخابيه
بدات مبك في تركيا وقادت المعارضه وحتى
ايضا اا الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بداوا في
حملاتهم وحضور تجمعات جماهيريه في حديد من
الولايات لكن لا شك ان المعارضه تريد
الاستفاده بشكل كبير من هذا القرار سواء
هذا القرار اقرته محكمه الاستئناف
والمحكمه العليا وبات نافدا او رفضته
محكمه الاستئناف او المحكمه العليا والغي
هذا القرار لكن هذه النقطه تريد المعارضه
البناء عليها لكسب مزيد من الاصوات
وتحديدا نتحدثنا المعارضه تريد التركيز
على انصار حزب العداله والتنميه الذين
صوتوا لاكرم امام اوغلو في الانتخابات
البلديه شكرا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الروسي الذي يفوت ان العقوبات
على روسيا تسببت بتضخم القياسي في الدول
الاوروبيه واضاف الرئيس الروسي انه هو رغم
العقبات فان الامدادات من روسيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي زادت باكثر من الضعف
خلال تسعه اشهر الماضيه واكد ان موسكو
ستعمد الى زياده امدادات الغاز الطبيعي
الى 70 مليار متر مكعب بوتن قال ان
الرهانات على انهيار اقتصاد روسيا بسبب
العقوبات فقط واشار الى ان موسى تبحث عن
شركاء افضل من الاتحاد الاوروبي
وفي اخر تطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
تستمر المعارك وتتبين وتيرتها من منطقه
الى اخرى خاصه في دنيازك حيث نفذت القوات
الروسيه هجوما المكثفا على بخموت في
محاوله لتطبيقها بالكامل كما تمكنت من
السيطره على بعض القرى المجاوره واعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه سيطرتها على نحو 80% من
مارينكا في حين تواصل تكثيف هجماتها على
كريم نايا وسبانوفو وكومبي من جهتها نفدت
القوه الاوكرانيه هجوما بواسطه راجمات
بتحديد العديد من المواقع التي تتواجد
فيها القوات الروسيه باستخدام الاشعه تحت
الحمراء في بخت وفق ما كشفت عنه صحيفه
تايمز بدوره قال جانيرا اوكراني ان روسيا
تريد ان تستنزف بلاده باطاله امادي الحرب
انه على المدى القصير من المستحيل تحقيق
نصر في الحرب وبالتالي يسعى لتحويل الصراع
الى مواجهه المسلحه طويله تهدف الى
استنفاذ اوكرانيا وشركائنا
القوى في الحرب باوكرانيا من خلال النظام
اسلحه امريكيه جديد يشمل هذه المره معدات
ذكيه متطوره وسيتم ضمها للسلاح الجو
الاوكرانيه هذه المعدات الالكترونيه سيتم
ارسالها الى الجيش الاوكرانيه حيث ستوفر
طريقه جديده
لاستهدف الوحدات العسكريه الروسيه ان كان
في البر او الجو وفقا ما نشرته صحيفه
واشنطن بوستر التقنيه العسكريه الجديده
التي اطلق عليها الباندا ذخيره الهجوم
المباشر المشترك ستشمل بالدرجه الاولى
اجهزه التحديد المواقع العالميه كما تابع
وذلك لضمان الدقه ايضا سيتم تثبيتها على
مجموعه متنوعه من الاسلحه كالقادفات
والطائرات المقاتله التي يستخدمها الجيش
الاوكراني في تنفيذ الهجمات المضاده ضد
القوات الروسيه ايضا سيتم تحويل الصواريخ
خائر الجويه غير الموجهه الى قنابل ذكيه
يمكنها استهداف المواقع العسكريه الروسيه
بدرجه عاليه من الدقه ويمكن ايضا للجيش
الاوكراني ان يستخدم هذه التقنيه في
القنابل التي يصل وزنها الى
907 كلم
القوات الاوكرانيه ستستخدم هذه المعدات
على الطائرات والاسلحه الارضيه وكل
الانظمه المحدده في ترسانه اوكرانيا التي
ستكون مرشحه لمثلي هذا التعزيز هذه
الاسلحه ايضا تعمل بشكل مختلف عن المعدات
التي توجه الصواريخ بالنظام تحديد المواقع
العالميه وفي حال تم تسليم هذه المعادات
سيشكل ذلك خطوه مهمه من جانب وعشان
لمساعدات اوكرانيا على سد القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
ويبحثوا قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي في قمه
تستمر اليوم وغدا تداعيات الحرب على
اوكرانيا حيث قال الرئيس الفرنسي ان القمه
الاوروبيه ستصادق على دعم اوكرانيا قيمتها
18 مليار يورو في 2023
وافاد بوجود تباينات بين مواقف الدول
الاوروبيه
اليوم على تحقيق توافق بشان هذه العقوبات
على روسيا
من جهه اخرى قال وكيل امين العام للامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه مارتن كرست ان
هناك صعوبات امام توسيع اتفاق الحبوب
ليشمل موانئها اضافيه واختصار فتره
التفتيش
لاتفاق تصدير الحبوب قد يحدث في المدى
القريب اعتقد ان تم
ديد حق امر رائع فكلما زادت كميه الحبوب
التي تخرج الى العالم كان ذلك افضل حقا من
وجهه نظر العالم لكنني لا اعتقد ان هذا
الامر وارد في الوقت الراهن
بعد قليل
الى جانب المشانق النظام الايرانيه يستهدف
المحتاجين برصاصه بالراس او الرئه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخر تطورات الحديثه
مقتل الجندي الايرلندي في قوات اليونيفيل
العامله في لبنان نقلت وكاله فرانسبريس عن
مصدر قضائي اللبناني ان الاليات التابعه
لقوات تعرضت لاصابه بسبعه طلقات جنوب
لبنان واشار المصدر القضائيين تلك
الرصاصات اصابه الجمهوريه الارلاندي في
الراس من الخلف ما ادى الى مقتله
قال مسؤوله وحده التنسيق والارتباط في
ميليشيا حزب الله اللبناني لرويترز ان
مقتل الجندي الايرلاندي في بلده العقبيه
جاء في حادث غير مقصود داعيا لعدم اقحام
الحزب في الحادثه التي وقعت بين اهالي
بلده العقبيه وافراد من الكتيبه
الايرلنديه في اشاره الى تنصل الميليشيا
من المسؤوليه والدفع بالاهالي الى الواجهه
الامم المتحده في لبنان
كانوا في طريقهم من نطاق عملياتهم في
الجنوب الى مطار
بيروتياديا عبر بلده العاقبيه التي تقع
ضمن نطاق نفوذ حزب الله لكنهم بشكل غير
اعتيادي توجهت نحوهم مجموعه مسلحه واطلقت
النار عليهم ما ادى الى مقتل احد الجنود
واصابه عدد بجراح احدهم في حاله خطيره
حفظ السلام في لبنان وجرح اخر انه تذكير
لنا بتضحيات غير العاديه التي يقدمها حفظه
السلام اتبعونا لنا بشكل دائم انهم يعملون
في بعض الاحيان في بيئات المعاديه وصعبه
للغايه وخطيره ويجب ان يكون دائما على
وعين بذلك
بيئه عدائيه وصوره ضبابيه حول الهجوم الذي
سرعان ما قامت اليونيفيل بالتنسيق لمعرفه
اسبابه الحقيقيه التفاصيل قليله ومتضاربه
رغم ادانه الدوله اللبنانيه ودعوه التحقيق
الا ان مراقبين يستبعدون التوصل الى نتيجه
سريعه او حاسمه في ظل سيطره حزب الله الذي
سارى الى النائي بنفسه عن الحادث وتصوير
الهجوم كانه سوء تفاهم مع السكر
لكن على خط الموازن تجري قوات اليونيفيل
مع الجيش اللبناني تحقيقاتها بالحادث الذي
مازال يشربه الكثير من اللبس والمعلومات
المتضاربه
انسنا الناسيين العربيه
[موسيقى]
في ايران ان لم تنفذ اعدامات او اعتقال
لات بحق المحتاجين تمارس السلطات وسياسه
الاضرار بهم باصابات تسبب لهم اكبر ضرار
ممكن واتحدث مدير الطوارئ في مستشفى سيناء
في طهران دكتور حسين كرمان عن سوق الحاله
المتظاهرين الجرحى وقال كرمان في تصريحات
صحفيه ان اكثر المتظاهرين اصيبوا في العين
والرئه والمناطق الحساسه في الجسم مدير
الطوارئ اضافنا سلطات الطالبات من امن
المستشفيات تقديم لائحه باسماء جرح
الاحتجاجات ما ادى الى امتناع العديد من
مراجعه المستشفيات واشار الى ان بعض
المراكز الطبيه الخاصه تقدموا العلاج
للمصابين بتخفيضات تتراوح بين 50 ومئه
بالمئه مؤكدا ان بعض الجرح يتلقون علاج
طبيا في منازلهم خشيه من الاعتقال
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو مؤثر للوالده
السجينه الهام افكاري تصرخ بالقرب من
بوابه السجن في شيراز مطالبات عن السلطات
باطلاق السراح ابنتها كما اكدت والدته
افكاري ان حياه ابنتها بخطر بعد دخولها في
اضراب عن الطعام منذ ثمانيه ايام
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
دوليه ان استنكر المستشار الالماني
انتهاكات النظام الايراني بحق المتظاهرين
قائلا ان الموقف الالماني مما يفعله
النظام واضح وسابتك كذلك
كما فعل الاتحاد الاوروبي انما تفعله
الحكومه الايرانيه غير مقبول وليس له مبرر
من يطلق النار على شعبه الحكومه الايرانيه
تفعل ذلك ولهذا السبب سلواصل اتخدم وقف
واضحه
[موسيقى]
حضاره المستشار القضائيه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه مما وصفته بتسيس النظام
القضائيه
المتسارعه لسن قوانين من شانها ان تؤدي
الى المساسي بمنظومه الحكم وبضروره حمايه
الاقليه من ضمن الاغلبيه هذا الموقف جاء
في ظل تخوف في عدد كبير من الاسرائيليين
من الابتزازه احزاب اليمين المتطرفه
والاحزاب الدينيه مقابل الانضمام الى
حكومته قد يؤدي الى المس بعلاقه الدين
بالدوله وعلاقه السلطه تنفيذيه بتلك
القضائيه
يبدو نتنياهو اسيرا لفوزه في الانتخابات
متوسطه بين اليمين الاكثر تطرفا المتمثل
ومودريتش واليمين الاكثر تدينا المتمثل
بشاس ويهدودها توراه ومضطر للقبول بمعظم
شروط هؤلاء للانضمام الى توليفته الحكوميه
حتى ان بدت انقلابا في شكل نظام الحكم
والعلاقه بين الدين والدوله والعلاقه بين
السلطه والجهاز القضائي كثيرون من
الاسرائيليين يخشون تبلور دوله شريعه
يهوديه في الحيز العام
اردته
في صالح الدوله وعدم تحويلها الى شيء رجيا
ومتطرف
انه هناك من يريد او لا يريد دوله شريعه
يهوديه نريد دوله طبيعيه
الى جانب القوانين الشخصيه التي يعمل
نتنياهو على تشريعها وتفصيلها على مقاسات
شركائه اليمنيين والمتدينين فان الاخطر
توافق الاحزاب اليمنيه على ضروره تشريع
قانون يغلب قرارات الكنيست على قرارات
المحكمه العليا ما قد يؤدي الى ديكتاتوريه
الاغلبيه على حساب حقوق الاقليه
ولن تقومه هنا دوله شريعه بل دوله نهتم
فيها بجميع مواطن اسرائيل في الاختلاف
المتبل 33 نائبا يدينون بتعليم التوراه
وفتاوي الحخمات فقط لا قوانين اسرائيل وقد
يكون لتنياهو الذي يصعب التنبؤ بما يخطط
له مرتاحا حاليا لانشغال الناس بشركائه
المتطرفين لا بمحاكمته في قضايا فساد
توتر بين شقي تعريف اسرائيل لنفسها
بيهوديه وديموقراطيه ليس جديده وطلب كانت
الغلبه ليهوديتها لانها وفق التعريب دوله
لليهود لا لجميع المواطنينها وجنوعها نحو
التطرف اليمني والدينيه يبدو متناغما مع
النزع اليمنيه لشارع الاسرائيلي زياد حلبي
العربيه القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
المنتخب المغربي
اغلى المسابقات الكرويه تلقى ارشاده كبيره
من وسائل الاعلاميه وصفات صحيفه لكيف
الفرنسيه المنتخب المغربي بالشجاعه بعد
المباراه المصريه مشيره الى ان اسود
الاطلس لم يمنح الفرصه للاعبين المنتخب
الفرنسي بالظهور بمستواهم المعتاد صحيفه
الديلمي البريطانيه كتبت ان المنتخب
المغربي كان الطرف الافضل والاقوى في معظم
فترات اللقاء غير ان نقول ما التتويز بكاس
العالم في المقابل الصحيفه
الايطاليه قالت ان المنتخب الفرنسي في
النهائي لكن التصفيقه والتحيات يذهبان
للمغرب وتطرقت صحيفه ماركا الاسبانيه
للحديث عن وليد الركراكي الذي دخل تاريخ
المجال بعد ما قاد طريقه ليصبح اول منتخب
عربي وافريق يظهر في الدوري قبل النهائي
لكاس العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى الدوحه العربيه
اليوم ليس هناك من مباريات بالامس كان فوز
لفرنسا ولكن كانت تصفيق والتحيات اكثر
يمكن
للمنتخب المغربي الاجواء اليوم ماذا عن
الجماهير المغربيه هل تركت الدوحه ام
ستنتظر لحضور المركز الثالث والرابع
نعم الكثير منهم ينتظر وهناك عائلات
مغربيه غادرت الى مطار محمد الخامس في
كازابلانكا او في الدار البيضاء والكثير
بقى هنا يعني هنا عائله من كازابلانكا من
الدار البيضاء وهنا فتيات دعني ابدا مع
الفتيات اذا سمحت اتينا من شيكاغو من
امريكا وهي مغربيه وتفضل ان تبقى هنا حتى
النهايه حتى تشجيع المنتخب المغربي يوم
السبت الذي سيواجه المنتخب الكرواتي همم
اللي بغيت نقول هو احنا
بالمنتخب المغربي ديالنا وكنفخر برجراكي
وليداته وغادي نبقاو معهم حتى اخر لحظه
حتى الاخر خطوه اللي غادي ياخذوها سندوهم
لحقاش ذاك الشيء علاش احنا جئنا على قطر
مشان سنه المنتخب المغربي وغالي نبقاو
معهم حتى الاخر نفس ان شاء الله ومفتخرين
بيهم وشكرا للمنتخب المغربي
هي المنتخب ديالنا همم وقطر تانكي سو ماتش
شكرا كثير قطر
نعم اتت من المغرب من طنجه وهي طبعا
نقالتي لن اغادر قطر حتى اخر رمق للمنتخب
هنا المنتخب المغربي السلام عليكم همم
طبعا احنا همم جئنا باش نشوفوا المنتخب
ديالنا المنتخب اللي اعطانا احلى من الكاس
اللي هي محبه الشعوب العربيه اللي شفناها
ولمسناها في طرقات قطر شفنا كيف فلسطين
كل كل كل كل العرب يعني
يعني هذا هذا شيء هذا شيء اكثر واكبر من
كاس من مجرد كاس هذا الحب هذا الشيء كبير
كثير والحمد لله فريقنا خلانا نعرف قيمتنا
عند الدول العربيه وعرفنا محبتنا قديش
بقلبهم وطبعا احنا معاهم للاخير ومش مطلوب
منهم يقدموا اكثر من اللي قدمه كفو
بالفعل ميسون الكثير من الجاهليه العربيه
المقيمين والذين اتوا اصبحوا جميعا مع
المنتخب المغربي يعني الكثير منهم كانوا
يشجع منتخبات اخرى قبل وصول المغرب او
المنتخب المغربي لهذه المرتبه ولكنهم
اليوم اصبحوا جميعا المغاربه تفضل انت
حضرتك من كذبلانكا انت متى وصلت
يعني فريقنا ولو ان هناك هزيمه ولكنه
بالنسبه
البطوله تنتهي بعد انه يوم السبت يوم باسم
بالنسبه لنا لانه بالمرتبه الثالثه ليس
بشيء همم يعني همم يسير وان شاء الله سوف
يقوم بما بما اوتي من جهد وقوه للفوز
ليضيف المرتبه الثالثه عالميا
ويمثل الدول الافريقيه والعربيه المسلمه
ان شاء الله لانه بطوله العالم لم تنتهي
بعد انه البوديوم في ثلاث مراكز المركز
الاول والثاني والثالث
والماتش يعني المقابله ديال اليوم السبت
باذن الله هي يعني على كل حال ليس طبعا
نحن نتمنى المغرب
المنتخب
شكرا لك دائما كنت واقفين بالاجواء
الحاصله في هذا المونديال العربيه بزاريا
سنتابع في التاسعه هذا المساء
في اكبر اضراب بتاريخ القطاع الصحي في
بريطانيا نحو مئه الف ممرض يمتنعون عن
العمل ليومنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ازمه ثقه كبيره يواجهها
الملياردير الامريكيه ايلوماسك مع
المستثمرين في شركه تسلا فعلى ما يبدو
فانت تحركات الاخيره للملياردير الامريكي
بخصوص صفه العصفور الازرق تويتر والاهتمام
الكبير الذي كان على حساب شركه السيارات
الكهربائيه تسلا ادى الى تمهل واستيا
كبيره من طرف المستثمرين فالعديد من
المستثمرين في الشركه عبروا عن تتمورهم من
تصرفات ماسك وطبعا من اهماله للملفات
العالقه التي تنتظر قرارات مصيريه في
الفتره الاخيره حيث تسبب هذا الاهمال من
مالك تويتر جديد في تراجع سهم تسلم موتورز
لنصف قيمته خلال ثلاثه اشهر الاخيره وصم
خوف المستثمرين من تفضيل ماسك لتويتر على
حساب تسلم كما ان بيع الرئيس تنفيذي لشركه
تسلا الومسك حوالي 22 مليون سهم بقيمه
تجاوزت الثلاثه مليار دولار خلال الاسبوع
الحالي لدعم منصه تويتر افقده ايضا ثقه
مستثمرين حيث اظهر الدراسه دراسه حديثه ان
معظم مواعيد ماسك بالفتره الاخيره كانت
لتويتر على حساب تسلا وهنا تم التشكيك في
دور لهم ماسك في شركه تسلا بعد ما اصبح
تويتر يشتغل اهتمامه
اذا اصدر مجلس اداره تسلا موتورز اعلان
عما يحدث لاداره الشركه في الوقت الحالي
يجب ان يتم تعيين شخص ما كرئيس تنفيذي
المؤقت حتى ينتهي سيناري انخفاض سهم
الشركه
لذا يطالب بعض
تسليم زمام الامور في احدى شركاته لشخص
مناسب او اعطاء اداره تويتر لشخص اخر حتى
يتمكن من اعاده تركيز طاقاته على شركه
السيارات الكهربائيه كما قال قريب لك احد
المستثمرين في تسلا بان انشغالات ماسك
بتويتر خطر على شركه تسلا للسيارات
الكهربائيه ووفقه مراقبين فان الاراء
السياسيه لاي لهم ماسك تضر
بتصورات العملاء عن سيارات تسلا
الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وضع
الشركات الصينيه المصنعه للرقائق على
القائمه السوداء بحسب بلومبرج والتي افادت
بان الولايات المتحده اضافت اكثر من 30
شركه صينيه الى القائمه السوداء التجاره
الى ان اداره البايرن تخطط لوضع شركه ينتس
ميموري تكنولوجيا الصينيه لصناعه الرقائق
وخمس 35 شركه صينيه اخرى في قائمه سوداء
للتجاره تمنعها من شراء مكونات امريكيه
معينه
ما تحرك الرئيس الجوبايدن والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب لحاجه الدعم في اعاده السباق
نحو البيت الابيض هناك الكثير من الناخبين
التصويت لوجوه جديده بعيدا عن بيض وترامب
[موسيقى]
منطقه الحديد ومخطات القطار انتقلت عدوى
الاضرابات في بريطانيا الى المشافي
والمراكز الطبيه سابقه هي الاولى من نوعها
في تاريخ القطاع الصحي في البلاد شلل تام
سيشهد هذا القطاع لمده يومين كاملين مرضى
السرطان وكبار السن اصحاب الامراض المزمنه
هم اكثر من سيعانون من تبيعات هذا الاضراب
ويدفعون ضاربته ضعفين وعكس التوقعات توعد
ريشي سوناك وحكمته بمواجهه هذه الاضرابات
بقرارات قاسيه بدلا من ان يبدا بالمفاوضات
لحلها من جذورها وفقا لما كان يتامله
المضربون والمرضى او حتى الاصحاء حقيقه
لاتحول هذا الشتاء على البريطانيين الى
الشتاء والتمر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا المشاهدين هو الاكبر في تاريخ نظام
الصحه الحكومي في بريطانيا يستمر لمده
يومين والمطالب واحده تحسين ظروف العمل
وطبعا رفع الاجور ودعم القطع الاضراب ادى
الى الغاء واعاده جدوله العديد من مواعيد
المرضى والعمليات
لنحو 70,000 شخص بحسب وزيره الصحه
صحيفه الجاردن اكدت ان هذا الاضراب ادى
لمخاوف كبيره في حكومه ريشه سوناتا وذلك
في اشاره الى ان الممرضين في بريطانيا
يضربون اليوم للمره الاولى بعد ان خفضت
فعليا الاجور على مدى العقد المنصرم بنسبه
20% من جهتها صحيفه الديليمي قالت ان
الرئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك يخطط
لفرد قوانين صارمه لمكافحه
الاضرابات وطبعا لحمايه الارواح وسبل عايش
خصوصا ان اضراب الموردين خلف قلقا حقيقيا
بنسبه للمسؤولين الصحيين والذي سيؤثر
بالدرجه الاولى على رعايه مرضى السرطان
وكبار السن من لديهم امراض مزمنه في حين
اكدت صحيفه ذا تايمز بان العاملين في قطاع
الصحه فيتحضرون
لاضرابات هي الاطول في تاريخ بريطانيا في
حاله لم تقم حكومه سوناك بتلبيه مطالبهم
على ماذا تتركز هذه المطالب على زياده
الاجور في مواجهه تضخم من تخطى الاحد 10%
مدفوعه بالارتفاع الحاده في اسعار الطاقه
ولا سيما بعد الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
في شهر تاريخي للاضطرابات في بريطانيا
يبدا الاضراب الاكثر انذارا بالخطر
والاكثر اثاره لقلق المرضى وعائلاتهم
يضربوا عشرات الالاف من الممرضين في
انجلترا ووينز وايلاند الشماليه في احتجاج
هو الاكبر في تاريخ قطاع الصحه البريطاني
بعد رفض الحكومه مطالب الممرضين بزياده
رواتبهم بنسبه 19% وهي نسبه تعتبرها
الحكومه اعلى من قدره تحملها
وصفها الممرضون بالمهينه بحقهم باعتبار
انهم اكثر الموظفين التضررا خلال الرائحه
كورونا فيما توعد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سوناك بفرض قوانين جديده للحد من
الاضطرابات وضمان الحد الادنى من مستويات
الخدمه
يوم ما اسوي هكذا وصف العديد الحاله التي
وصلت اليها بريطانيا التي تعاني من اوضاع
المعيشيه سيئه يشعر بها العديد من
المقيمين والعاملين هنا
تقريبا الى احد يتخذ قرار الاضراب
باستخفاف ولاسيما الممرضين الممرضين على
الخط الامامي طوال الوقت
ليس كافيا وانهم بحاجه الى القيام بشيء
اكثر جواريا
نحن مرهقون للغايه ونعاني من نقص في عدد
الموظفين منذ سنوات عديده وبشكل عام منذ
كوفيد
فنحو 50,000 وظيفه شاغره يعاني من نقصها
قطاع التمريض ما يعني تكدس اعداد المرضى
على لوائح الانتظار الذين وصلت اعدادهم
الى سبعه ملايين ومن المتوقع ان تطول
اللائحه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
[موسيقى]
رصد تقرير الحقوقي صادر عن مكتبه حقوق
الانسان في مارب اكثر من 2600 حاله انتهاك
مارستها الميليشيات الحوثيه طالت القطاع
الصحي وتواقيم الطبيه في مارب منذ مطلع
لعام 2015 التقرير الذي تزامن مع اليوم
العالمي لحقوق الانسان كشف عن عمليه
استهداف متعمده لطواقم الاسعاف
بقدر حرصها على استهداف المجندين تحرص
المليشيات الحوثيه على استهداف المسعفين
بالتزامن مع كل عمليه قصف صاروخيا نحو
مارب شواهد كثيره تؤكد تعمد المليشيات
الحوثيه تدمير القطاع الصحي واستهداف
الطواقم الطبيه في اكثر من منطقه رصدها
تقرير انتهاكات حقوق الانسان بلغت اكثر من
2600 انتهاك منذ مطلع العام 2015 حتى
اليوم
بين اكثر في اكثر من ذلك اللي هي المنطقه
همم
سيارات الاسعافات الطواجن الطبيه
التحتيه للقطاع الصحيه وقتل الاطباء
والممرضين
والاجهاز على الضحايا جرائم ومركبه
ارتكبتها الميليشيات الحوثيه راحه ضحيتها
و 39 طبيبا وعاملا في القطاع الصحي بماربه
خلال السنوات الحرب وتدمير مئات المنشات
الاعتداء على اطراف الطبيه والكادر الطبي
بحيث نلاحظ جماعه الحوثي محمد هذا
الاستهداف لا اكثر من مره حيث تضرب مره
تضرب بالمره الاولى حتى تاتي الطموح همم
الاسعافات الطبيه وتقوم سدادها وهذا ما
يتنافى معه القانون الدولي الانساني
التقرير الحقوقي الذي اصدره مكتب حقوق
الانسان بمارب تزامنا مع اليوم العالمي
لحقوق الانسان حمل الامم المتحده
والمنظمات الدوليه المسؤوليه القانونيه في
الانتهاكات الحوثيه مع تسبب بمكاتبها
الرئيسيه في صنعاء بايقاف خمس حملات
دوائيه في مارب وكذا ايقاف الامداد
الدوائي ل 2005 مرفقا طبيا
ارماني
2785 مريضا من العلاجات الخاصه بالامراض
المزمنه محمود الحميدي العربيه مارب
نهايه التاسعه هذا المساء نذكر بالعناوين
ثلاث مراحل تنتهي بلقائه مع الاسد
الرئيس الروسي للغرب رهانكم على انهيار
اقتصادنا فشله وسنبحث عن شركاء افضل من
الاوروبيين
مصدر اللبناني يؤكد جندي اليونيفيل قتل
برصاصه الراس وحزب الله يضع سكان العاقبيه
بالواجهه
لتفضيله تويتر
وسعر سهم الشركه الي ينخفض للنصف
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه ولكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره مع 360 و راويه ما هي ابرز ملفاتك
اليوم راويه تفضل
سنتحدث عن استمرار الاعدامات للمتظاهرين
في ايران وايضا هاري وماجن وجديد الحلقات
التي نزلت اليوم على نادي فليكس